tìm một số hạn chế cho các kiến trúc mô hình, exception, FNF hay là các gì.
Sau đó em đi tập trung nghiên cứu một số các kiến trúc cơ bản của exception,
em cũng tìm hiểu vào từng phần.
Sau khi tìm hiểu kiến trúc exception cơ bản,
em có xem một số các exception đã được cải tiến trong các bài báo.
Ví dụ như là các cái cơ chế mà nó tiếp hợp với lại cơ chế hoặc là cái kinh nghiệm của SINF
Thì đấy là một số cái phát triển của các cơ chế cơ bản và có cái sự cải thiện trong một số các cái bài trước đó
Và cũng đấy cũng có cái hướng là từ đấy tạm thời là dự kiến ra một cái gọi là theo cái hướng này
Hãy subscribe cho kênh La La School Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
chủ yếu là em tạo tìm phần các kỹ thuật này hoạt động thực hiện như thế nào để đảm bảo những phần trong các kỹ thuật của nó.
Tiếp đến về phương pháp VGI thì tôi có thể kê các phương pháp VGI trong các bài đọc thách đi vào cách thức giảm cũng tương tự.
em tìm hiểu những phương pháp cơ bản
ví dụ như cam hay là đường sát
tìm hiểu những phương pháp cải tiến
tức là đã được cải tiến trong các phần báo tới
hoặc các phương pháp sát đã cải tiến trong một số phần báo mới đến đây
ví dụ như là cải tiến về các công thức phân hoạch
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Ví dụ như là cải tiến trong phân cấp tổ chức cây để tính các nguyên minh để kiểm tra, để cải tiến cách kết hợp các nguyên minh của các đặc trưng,
rồi là cách cải tiến để lấy mẫu, cách để lấy mẫu để chúng ta tính, và tổ chức các vấn đề các kỹ mạng,
tức là các kiến thức mạng để hỗ trợ trong việc phát triển các tác.
Từ đấy mình cũng có dự kiến của phần này.
Tuy nhiên ở đây trong vừa rồi em tập trung em mới đang dự kiến ra
lúc tranh tổng thể của 2 loại dung này.
Về phần thứ 3 thì nó khó hơn người ta nghe,
em cũng chưa kỹ hơn cái phần này
tập trung hướng tới của em
thì em đi vào cái
đi vào cái phần chủ yếu
đi vào 2 cái phần đầu
phần thứ nhất là cái phần về sẽ tập trung vào cái phần
giả sát các cái kiến trúc này
và cách thức thì cũng là
đi từ các kiến trúc căn bạc
xong rồi là sẽ có một cái
kẻ kiến của các kiến trúc đấy
thì xác định rõ các kẻ kiến này
nó sẽ có các đặc trưng của
các kẻ kiến này và có các cái
tìm hiểu và giải thích được tất cả chi tiết về cái cải tiến này.
Từ đấy thì em sẽ xem, kiểm tra một số dự kiến
để có thể hỗ trợ ra một dự báo về một kế hoạch mới.
Thứ hai là tập trung vào phần phương pháp nghiên cứu
Trong đó, trong các phương pháp kế hoạch, mình sẽ chủ yếu là nghiên cứu về phương pháp về sát, cũng đã có các nội dung về sát cơ bản và biến đổi, và cũng đã có một số những cải tiến tổ hợp với các cải tiến của sát.
thì em sẽ cố gắng tập trung vào đánh giá những kẻ tiến này rất cụ thể để có một cái bài tổng thể chi tiết trong phương pháp sắp này.
Vướng của em tập trung vào hai cái kẻ tiến này để tập trung vào hai cái hướng.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Bởi vì sự phát triển của các kiến trúc này nó không chỉ có một cái kiến trúc này khác mà có thể chúng ta có thêm nhiều hơn.
Thì em sẽ phục vụ phần đấy và sẽ chỉ ra, cố gắng chỉ ra được cái trực tạp của các kiến trúc này.
Các bạn hãy đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé.
Cơ bản có phần cải tiến, cách trúc cải tiến, các bước cải tiến chi tiết, những ưu hỏng và những vấn đề đó.
Chúng em sẽ làm báo cáo trước để thử thấy trong cơ bản dự kiến chúng ta có tài liệu trong tuần sau để phổ trung những vấn đề này.
thì cũng đã có phần này nhưng mà em chưa kịp hiểu lắm
nên là em không thể giải thích cái phần hỗn hợp đấy
chưa hiểu hết kỹ vì một số cái khái niệm của em cũng không hiểu
Vậy bộ dữ liệu mẫu như thế này?
Dạ, về bộ dữ liệu mẫu như thế này
về so sánh các cái bộ dữ liệu khác
thì em cũng tìm được cái bộ dữ liệu này
hiện nay thì em cũng có cái tải những cái bộ dữ liệu
Các bạn có thể nhớ đăng kí cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
để giải thích thì cũng mới đang dừng mức độ là giải thích ra nhưng mà chưa được thử minh thông qua các kiến thức chứng để minh hoạt các cái phần gì đấy
thì chúng em xin lấy ra cái phần dữ liệu 2 cái đặc biệt là 2 cái phần file của bộ dữ liệu này thì sẽ bổ sung cái phần cụ thể để cái
Ok, 81 là có ghế hội thảo AI nhé. Nếu kịp thì gửi hội thảo ở nơi hợp lý nhất đấy.
Vậy thì chính xác là sang phần thứ 3 thì em sẽ cố gắng gửi.
Nghĩa là cái đích tới là một là em sẽ bổ sung thêm cái phần đặc biệt một số kiến trúc.
Cái kiến trúc đấy cũng phải đối hợp.
Hai nữa là em sẽ đẩy tất cả thành phần ở trong kiến trúc được được kê.
Về phương pháp thì cũng là phương pháp sạc thì có phương pháp thân bản thì em hiểu rồi
Nhưng phương pháp cải tiến, phương cách cải tiến đây thì em sẽ có hiệu của báo cáo này
Vừa rồi thầy chỉ cho cái chỗ về bộ dữ liệu thì em sẽ làm rõ so sánh bộ dữ liệu đấy có hình chữ có thể
Rồi cảm ơn em
Nó có, bây giờ hết rồi em
Ai báo cáo thế này?
Mới năm ngoái còn. Năm ngoái xài rồi đó anh. Mắc hết cái còn này rồi.
Bây giờ thì hết rồi. Giờ phải trả phí rồi.
Hả? Bây giờ làm gì bộ tiền viên nữa?
Bây giờ hết rồi. Process nó hết rồi.
Còn à?
Ừ.
Không còn nữa.
Hết rồi. Từ năm ngoái là nó xài cái đấy rồi.
Nó bắt kết cái dự án hồi xưa làm cái invoice.
Chatbot invoice nè. Tự động đọc hóa đơn.
Từ đó là đã phải mua thêm rồi. Thì thì hết.
Từ đầu năm nay á. Cái process này hết rồi.
Mình có trách Shell Attention khi mà đưa thương vào trong mô hình STDN gốc hoạt động.
Em có trách thêm bác hoạt toán về Fusion này.
Có trách thêm Adversion và cũng đã có kết quả.
Rồi em sẽ khai quát lại các quan hệ đặc biệt từ STDN.
Tiến trình và rút góp, số dữ phép tính từ 10 tháng.
Rồi xả lốt xuống phần công việc thứ 2, chính là kết quả ESDN đó.
Và qua bài SIS, tức là SIS,
Từ SPDN em đã thay 1 phần CNN thành 1 phần SHELL ATTENTION
Số tham số đi thêm không nhiều, chỉ khoảng 169
Đây là phần kiến trúc
Phần giá dấu vết sản phẩm cũng đã kỳ nguyên từ bài SPDN
Phần này em có đi qua về chỗ này em đã thay SHELL ATTENTION
Tức là block SHELL ATTENTION ở trong này em đã thay cảnh nhánh ESR
và cảnh nhánh tổng hợp các đặc trưng dấu vết TLCSRB
Đối với SRB thì cái kích thước ma trận mà nó nhọc thì em để kích thước của cái block SA là kích thước block vàng
và tự đúng với ma trận dấu vết C là kích thước nằm và ma trận dấu vết T thì là kích thước phối SA này
thì đây là cái tầm thái quát qua của cái mô hình mà em đã thể hiện
Trong Shell Attention này thì em có tham khảo từ bài SCCB từ 2018
Đối với cái cơ chế chú ý, trước thì cơ chế chú ý trong mô hình SD chưa có
Trong cái nhánh tổng hợp các đặc trưng, các dấu phích, em có đưa thêm cơ chế chú ý là nhấn thêm một màn chặn I.
Số lượng tham số thì tăng lên 969 tham số khi mà em tìm cái Shared Tension.
Về phần hàm vấn mắc thì vẫn như thế nhưng mà tuy nhiên em vẫn điều chỉnh cái trọng số trong cái hàm vấn mắc.
Đây là cái khối Edge, tức là cái khối cho những phân loại.
Ở đây thì em đã nâng lên thành 50.
Nó có nguyên do tại vì cái khối stress tension thì nó nặng về cái phần con huyết
Và trong khi đấy thì cái mạng của em thì kết quả nó cũng cao đất tệ
Khi mà giảm cái tỉ lệch MSR đến tốt bắt đầu của SEM
Nó tăng nó lên từ 50 để cho nó tươi tươi thành lý
Em đã đi qua được cái mô hình SASR mà em đã cải thiết lên
Bây giờ đến phần cái thỏa toán thấp nhất các mô hình
Thực ra thấp nhất các mô hình thì có ra nhiều phương pháp
phương pháp lấy trung bình các kết quả, phương pháp lấy trung bình, hoặc phương pháp giải trí, tức là lai lai của 2 phương pháp ở trên
hoặc sử dụng một cây quyết định, cây trăng cường trong giảm quyết định giữa các mô hình nhau
thì đầu tiên sẽ phải chuẩn hóa đầu xác của tất cả các mô hình để dẫn dàng từ 0 đến 1
Những câu thức này là câu thức chuẩn hóa dặn tiêu chuẩn
Sau đấy thì em sẽ có tập toán, chọn cái tổ tập tốt nhất
Tức là em sẽ có khá là nhiều mô hình
Nhưng mà mình thấy sẽ có cả mô hình Vision Transformer
Vision Transformer
Đúng
Cái kiểu socon hay là fix này thì là cái
mô hình em cải thiện của em
Mô hình LDA thì cũng là một cái sô tang ở đây
và cái mô hình No-ADV
tức là mô hình STDN của em, nhưng mà em tắt cái nhánh phân biệt
rủi kháng trong gạm đi. Bằng cái thuật toán trong Tham Lan thì em giữ được lại một cái
tổ lọc mô hình, một bốn mô hình và nó cho cái lỗi là thật nhất
Ở đây là một số các thuật toán mà em đã trải thưởng nghiệm
Trong này em có phân ra thuật toán nào sử dụng nhãn để học trong việc hợp thích mô hình
và thuật toán nào sử dụng để đưa vào trong phương pháp hợp thích mô hình.
Thì ở đây thì thuật toán trung bình hạn, thuật toán cơ bản nhất
thì nó cho kết quả tốt nhất là 0,76 trên mũ text để đổi.
Một số phương pháp khác nâng cao hơn nhưng mà là cho kết quả tệ hơn.
Em có huấn luyện các mô hình kém remote ở đây, đánh xét các mô hình.
Thì phần lớn các mô hình đều tấn luyện với tỉ lệ lỗi trên 1
Nhưng mà tuy nhiên bằng phương pháp 1 trung bình 2
Thì kết quả tỉ lệ lỗi của nó đã xuống được dưới 0,76
Em cũng thường thêm bớt một số mô hình
Trong đấy đặc biệt đưa ra mô hình kiến trúc tế xuất
S-A-X
Nếu như bỏ nó đi
Thì tỉ lệ lỗi nó tăng lên không bằng mô hình số tài
Nó đóng một vai trò rất là trắng tròn
Một số mô hình khác bỏ đi thì nó cũng không thay đổi nhiều
Tăng đến 0% hoặc là 0,5%
Nó cũng đang kể bằng cho mô hình SKS rồi.
Đây là cái bảng mà em so sánh với các số tài trên 4CNR Scoop lần này.
Mô hình mà nó có kết quả tốt nhất bây giờ là mô hình DPM.
Mô hình LDA thì họ mới đăng vào trên Tokai.
Chứ họ chưa có công bố được.
Nhưng mà tuy nhiên vẫn đưa vào report.
Khi mà so sánh trên thì lấy lỗi AUC hay là lấy phaser.
Mô hình của em tốt nhất trong tất cả các chỉ số.
Bên đây em kết luận, với cơ bản phương pháp của em đề xuất thì thẳng trên các số tài trong phần số này
và còn đóng góp thêm về S, A, S, R
Về mặt giới hạn thì nó cũng rất rõ ràng
Cái phép gồm này thì nó cũng giống như là chỉ bắt nốt cái quả mặt của các mô hình
muốn cải thiện tiếp cái kết quả này thì phải
một là đề xuất mô hình mới, hai là sẽ bổ sung thêm các mô hình vào trong phần
Em gửi lại thầy slide này nhé
Vâng
Còn em báo cán không?
Chúng ta đã sử dụng một số nội dung về phương pháp lựa chọn thoa bởi máy PNC.
Thì ở đây thì đối với họ thì em tập trung vào nội dung này là
thêm bản thân sử dụng để diễn kiến rất hiểu.
Thế thì mục tiêu nhất là về đại thiện về sự không dịch dữ liệu.
Ở đây là tụi em tập trung vào đại thiện về nhận dịch dữ liệu về nhãn.
Thứ hai là không lưu ý về nhãn và số lượng bảo.
Thứ hai là về nhận định được số lượng và lớp kiếm của các cây đường.
Đầu tiên là về bài tháp của ESPN 2026.
Em đã kết hợp Star với Logix Assets.
Thì ở đây thì cái Startup này là để truyền hóa cái đặc trưng tại tên và cái Office của chúng mình là để ưu tiên kể các tổng hợp thứ đó kìa
Thì khi mà tựa có các copy cũng như là copy một bản thân liệt và copy một loại thì có một số cái hạn để đối với MyPSP để đánh thức là về cái vụ đó không rõ gì là thông tin
Thứ hai là trước chương trình hành xử lý cái tổng hợp kiến sẽ có một chiếc vẫn sử dụng cái phép pháp về tưởng
Thứ ba là nó còn quá nhẹ cho bệnh viện, nó có đối với bộ test ai hiểu thì chắc là không phải thứ 5 nhưng mà cái collision nó không phải thứ 6, thì có cảnh báo nhiều hơn nhiều.
Chính vì thế thì dù những cái đặc biệt này thì em có hình vị cái hướng nghiên cứu nào là đối với bệnh viện mà không có.
Câu hỏi này sẽ tiến hành xử lý tại server và tiến hành ưu tiên các đề nghệ tiền ở các lớp tiềm
3 hình ứng quan trọng nhất là hiểu tình đủ lạnh ở server
Thứ hai là hiểu tìm cái khu vực bộ theo cái điều kiện đấy là
bởi vì nếu mà mình luôn luôn bật cho nó công ty ký lập kiếm
thì nó sẽ có những dấu lập nhiều, cảnh báo rất là nhiều
tùy vào các lớp thì mình sẽ bật cái công ty ký lập kiếm
và sẽ gửi đến server đấy thông tin
nhất là về cái trọng số của mô hình
và thứ hai nữa là về cái số lượng lớp của tài chất lượng đấy
Các bạn có thể nhớ đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé.
số lượng màu của lớp đó, chưa biết là lớp nào đó là thiếu
mà chúng ta có thể xử lý
và star bây giờ là điều để giảm lệnh trọng trưng
nhưng mà chưa thể xử lý liên quan đến lệnh nhãn
mà chỉ là liên quan đến chuẩn loại không thể trọng trưng
tổng hợp ở trên
phép ls là điều chỉnh smog 1
nhưng mà server vẫn đang dùng về phép avg
phép 2, phép 2s là bài mẫu của VNST 06
thì tiêu chí mới xích mốc bổ, cải thiện deco lớp yếm nhờ lưu ích, nhưng vẫn sử dụng tham số để cố định
và thứ hai là lưu ích lò lỉa thông tin và cảnh báo cao
thứ ba là lưu ích của roto và roto thì hỗ trợ lớp chung quan sát nhưng ti phí truyền thông hiện tại cao
khoảng 112,5kb trên 1 vòng
Từ những vấn đề này, có thể là nhận biết môi trường trong lớp thiếu thay sự kiện xây dựng hay tài liệu xây dựng hơn và vẫn bảo hành kỹ thuật thông.
Từ nãy đến lúc phát biểu xuất của mình.
Đầu tiên là các dữ liệu thú luyện tại các cây đần và chất thú luyện sẽ được kiểu hóa bằng star, như quả PNCT.
Sau khi được thú luyện thì sẽ gửi 2 thông số lên cho server.
Thứ nhất là về trọng số của mình, thứ hai là số lượng nhám của lớp ở cây đần đấy.
Để mình nhận được lớp nào là lớp kiếm và số lượng mở cuộc tại cái lần đấy so với lần khác
Sau đó chị em tiến hành sử dụng cái PPA này là
Thứ nhất là, nếu mà mình sử dụng cái 5DFCT thì là sử dụng cộng tổng thép AMG
Thì cộng tổng trung tính chung
Nhưng mà một số cây lượng thì nó chất cộng với lớp kiếm ở đấy
Mình chỉ dùng trọng nguyên dung thì trọng nguyên dung đó là nhiễu
và nó làm ảnh hưởng so với classical
Ở đây thì em chỉ là tổng cọng của những cái làm bóng lớn ở đây
Lăng ở phần backbone là cái phần cơ bào của mô hình
thì em sử dụng CPU
Thay vì em sử dụng bởi vì nó chỉ có một tỷ số trong một cái lần
Chính vì thế thì em không tiến hành trọng trung bình chung của số lượng mẫu của cái lần đấy
Không tính trung bình chung của số lượng mẫu của cái lần đấy so với tổng cục mà sẽ tiến hành đấy là
Ví dụ có 3 thì em sẽ lấy 1 phần 3 của cái trung bình chung của từng nhãn 1 sau đó tổng lại
để tổng số sẽ ưu tiên được lớp kiểm ở đây
Thứ ba là lcdn
để thành để là bật hoặc không bật chế độ lupit assessment
hoặc
là mình sử dụng bình thường, theo từng lợi ích, từng ngã, từng lớp
Thực ra tại đây thì em đã có một số kết quả, một số so sánh so với phương pháp của VNCT
Nhất là về xử lý trung cộng thì mình cũng đã có phương pháp đại báo
Đại báo này đã có so với bài VNCT
Vậy nên là các point theo lớp cũng như là thử nghiệm của bộ thử nghiệm bài này đã có so với bài VNCT
Về hóa hình nghiệp thì em sử dụng 4 nguồn dữ liệu. Đấy là TOR-90, TOR-95, SIRP và CIC-IS-200.
Về cấu hình nghiệp thì em sử dụng số lượng gần gần 10. Sử dụng đối tượng tích với tắc số 1.3 và 1.5 và sử dụng 4 kết quả nguồn dữ liệu tầm 0.5 và 1 kết quả nguồn dữ liệu tầm 0.1.
của mình để so sánh với nguyên tố của bệnh hoạt hóa.
Trên đây là một số kết quả chính của chúng ta.
Nhất là về kết quả Macro S1 cũng như S1-4 của chúng ta
của phương pháp đề xuất là F-CF-A là phương pháp đề xuất của bệnh hoạt hóa.
Về so sánh đối với từng hệ phần, từng hệ phần trong phương pháp đề xuất,
khi mà ta tiến hành tổng hợp lại cả phương pháp mà mình đặt ra
thì có kết quả tốt hơn so với từng khuất như lẻ.
Thứ hai là về tiến hành so với các thương cứu ở đây thì
của mình đầu tiên cái bộ có 3 mẫu là bộ CSC, S-AMT và B15 thì kết quả rất là tốt lắm.
Và chúng ta đã có kết quả tốt hơn của các thương cứu nước ngoài đó.
Bộ con AMT trong số mẫu, mẫu kiếm của cái bộ đấy nó rất là ít.
Vì thế thì cái này mình nghĩ mình thấp hơn một chút là không ít.
em xin phép báo cáo nhanh tuần trước là em cũng đã thành công bảo vệ thạc sĩ anh thì
là đề tài thì đây là thông số mà em có thuyết trình ạ thì hiện tại thì các thầy
có nói là
so với các mô hình đề xuất thì chỉ có mô hình
SMOTE và mô hình của em
là có thông số khả quan
các mô hình khác thì là thông số
và kết quả đưa ra là
nó chưa đủ thuyết phục
nên với cả là các bài
báo khoa học mà em dựa vào
thì là em có chỉ ra rằng là
hiện nay để tiết kiệm chi phí
và bởi vì mô hình dữ liệu rất là lớn
nên là người ta sẽ ưu tiên dùng phương pháp
SMOTE còn phương pháp sinh dữ liệu
để bổ sung vào cơ sở dữ liệu
dấu hiệu thì là đang em như em đang tìm hiểu thì đang chưa có nhiều bài báo nào thì sau khi em áp
dụng thì đây là kết quả thì đối với mô hình một thông thường thì là các dấu hiệu cơ bản thì mô
hình có khả năng nhận biết rất rõ Tuy nhiên là các dữ liệu mà có yếu tố đặc trưng hơn thì thường bị
lẫn vào ví dụ ở đây là nhóm mà mục tiêu là sinh dữ liệu bộ lần thì lại đôi lúc lại có thêm một số
có một số nhãn về xanh dụng và đôi lúc mà nó quên chưa đóng dấu câu như phần em bôi đỏ thì ở đấy câu
lệnh đấy là câu lệnh sẽ bị lỗi và sẽ bị chặn nghe tức còn dữ liệu môi của em ạ thì là ở hai nhóm
22 nhóm đầu tiên thì là các cái dấu hiệu về bộ lần vài lần là mô hình là môi của em đã có khả
năng sinh ra rồi và đã được chặn
chặn ở đây nghĩa là
cái tường lửa nó đã nhận biết được là đây
có những dấu hiệu tấn công không phải là
những dấu hiệu nhiễu nữa
còn đối với 2 cái mô hình còn lại
là Time và Union thì cấu trúc
ngư pháp nó yêu cầu cao hơn
nên khi mà sinh ra dữ liệu
thì mô hình của em lại đang không học được
thế nên là sinh ra dữ liệu
nhiễu rất là nhiều và không khỏe năng
khai thác thực tế ạ. Thì trong tuần này
là em cũng đã cố gắng thay đổi
các cái thông số ở trong mô hình
nhưng mà kết quả thì vẫn đang chưa được khả quan
thì hôm nay em trình bày để mong là thầy cho em một định hướng để có thể cải thiện
thì hiện tại mục tiêu của em là em cho rằng là
đối với các loại dữ liệu thông thường
nghĩa là có dữ liệu tấn công lớn mà nhiều
thì phương pháp SMOTE nó sẽ ưu việt hơn về mặt chi phí
tuy nhiên là ở những mẫu mà yêu cầu ngữ pháp cao hơn
thì mô hình của em sẽ tốt hơn để có thể bổ sung vào
thì em đang hiện tại đang đi theo hướng này đây là kết quả của em
thì hiện tại sẽ có hai nhóm đầu tiên là hai nhóm bên trên thì cấu trúc của nó nó sẽ rất là đơn giản
nó chỉ cần yêu cầu ví dụ như là nhóm Aaron là cố gắng sinh ra lỗi
còn nhóm Boland là cố gắng ép
Cố gắng
Thì nói chung là 2 mẫu này
Thì nó sẽ yêu cầu ngữ pháp rất là thấp
Còn 2 mẫu còn lại
Thì nó sẽ yêu cầu phải
Thứ nhất là phải đúng cơ sở dữ liệu
Mà nó tấn công vào
Thì nói chung là 2 mẫu dưới nó yêu cầu cao hơn
Đến cả phương pháp smooth
Nó cũng không làm ổn hết
Thì
Em đang định là
Tập trung vào 2 phương án khó hơn
Nhưng mà 2 phương án khó hơn
Hiện tại em đang cố gắng mà vẫn chưa có cải thiện
Nên là mình đang mong muốn xin định hướng của thầy ạ
Em đưa mô hình này, chứ có mẻ quá không
Đây là mô hình của em, em dựa trên các phần em đánh dấu vuông là em 4 phương án đề xuất ạ
Đầu tiên là em sẽ cố gắng tách theo chuỗi cú pháp SQL
thì thay vì đưa vào các cái thông số như kiểu 123
thì em sẽ biến thành keyword là number
hoặc là các cái cụ SQL thì em sẽ chuẩn hóa nó lại
để tránh việc phải học quá nhiều dữ liệu mà có chung mục đích ạ
tiếp theo là trong bộ sinh
thì là em sẽ tăng số lượng chuỗi
thay vì ở bài gốc của tác giả này là 20
thì em sẽ tăng lên thành 160
còn huấn luyện trước bộ sinh thì em sẽ tăng cường việc huấn luyện trước bộ sinh để tránh việc mô hình bị xụp đổ quá sớm
và cuối cùng là em sẽ kết hợp điểm thưởng
thì thay vì nhận biết là dữ liệu thật hay giả thì sẽ phải thêm một cái nữa là liệu dữ liệu đấy có cấu trúc SQL không ạ
thì đây là 3 thành phần ạ
thì các thầy hội đồng cũng đã nhận ra là em có một vấn đề khá lớn với phần điểm thưởng ạ
Bởi vì đầu tiên là cái hàm mà đánh giá mô hình SQL
Thì nó lại có sự tương đương với hàm đánh giá
Nghĩa là kiểu vừa đạp bóng vừa thổi còi
Thế nên là nó sẽ khiến cho mô hình của em là có xu hướng là cố gắng học những cái thành phần để điểm cao
Thì đây là phần em cũng đang cố gắng tìm hiểu để cải thiện
Còn các thành phần khác thì em chưa gặp vấn đề gì
Phần sau anh muốn nghe rõ về vỉ huẩn của tính như thế nào
Vâng, thế thì phần sau em sẽ làm sai chi tiết hơn về phần này, có giải thích
Thầy thấy còn về định hướng phần làm của em có cần phải chỉnh sửa hay là em cứ làm rõ các vấn đề
Rõ, viết cái bài hội thảo dựa trên cái này
Cái bài hội thảo, vâng
Làm sao cái chuỗi sinh ra nó có nghĩa hơn
Xem cái vỉ huẩn của mình nó đúng chứ
Rồi, hình chính với em đến đây là hết
Hẹn gặp lại các bạn trong những video tiếp theo.
Vậy là loại trùng lọc Epoch, đầu tiên phải ghi lại, còn đối tên là 4 đoạn xe hông hơi so với lần trước.
Mình cũng tìm hiểu xem cái kết quả của vận cho ý không.
4 lần đầu chạy thì mùi air, hôm trước thì em đang gặp vấn đề có mùi man nang, nó về giá trị không hết.
Giá trị này là giá trị thể hiện cái true positive càng thấp thì càng tốt.
Hôm trước là thầy có thắc mắc tại sao mà nó về không thì em có kiểm tra lại, chạy lại và theo cái phương pháp như thế chung hướng dẫn.
Hôm qua mình đã bỏ 1 thường lạc đi và mình kiểm tra lại chỉ chính xác
Thì cái chỉ số này thì hiện tại là 3 tháng trước
Cái nguồn man D22 này thì em cũng đã trẻ gặp trên cái bộ dữ liệu của DB
Về mặt so sánh thì cái bộ man D22 này, nguồn man D22 này thì vẫn đang tốt hơn cái man gan gốc
Còn cái nguồn cuối cùng, cái nguồn mình đang đề xuất mới
với mùi mát Auto High Factor Nga
mùi này trong lần đầu tiên em chạy
kết quả nó ra rất là tốt như thế này
có một vài 1ml thì gần như vượt qua 100%
có khoảng 2ml thì vẫn hiện ra các mẫu màu đậu sinh ra
em đang chạy lần thứ 2 để kiểm tra kết quả này của mình có vấn đề gì không
hiện tại với lần 1 thì những kết quả này của em
thì em đã có tất cả các file CFP sinh ra
và em có dùng các công cụ tống kê
thì các mẫu dữ liệu sinh ra thì nó không có vấn đề gì thường vẹn
và nó là những dữ liệu không bị trúng lặng
thì nếu mà em chạy thêm một lần nữa
hoặc là một tháng, một tháng lần nữa
nếu mà cái lắp, cái kết quả của mình không có vấn đề gì cả
thì cái này cũng là hoàn toàn đã đạt yêu cầu mình đặt ra
là mẫu sử dụng sinh ra bằng nguồn mạng của tổng cộng thức đô với các bạn sẽ sinh ra một mẫu hoặc chất lượng.
Thì đấy là cái mà em đang chờ kết quả lần thứ 2.
Với kết quả lần 1 thì toàn bộ dữ liệu của em cũng đã check
và thông qua các công cụ AI để có check những bộ hiệu của mình sinh ra.
Đây là bộ dữ liệu mà em cũng đã sau một lần chạy
thì đều tập hợp thành một cái nước kho dữ liệu
có một bước đồng kê lại. Ví dụ ở đây là pho dữ liệu, thì các file CSV này sinh ra chính là mỗi một file sẽ chứa các mát độc sinh ra
và các bộ mát độc này mà đã vượt qua được cái bộ phát hiện mát độc này thì em cũng đều lưu lại để làm cái minh chứng.
Cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi và đăng ký kênh của mình.
tháng 9 thì em cũng mong muốn nếu mà được thì em hoàn thiện bài trong thời gian thứ 3 thì thấy được.
Hoàn toàn kết quả rồi.
Vâng, cái kết quả này thì em đã, đến thời điểm này em thấy em đã thêm một phần kiểm tra nữa
thì em cũng đã kết quả được.
Cái hội thảo SOICT thì em cũng đã tìm hiểu qua về các chủ điểm để họ gửi bài
thì họ có 2 mục và nó khá là khác nhau.
Họ sẽ có một phần chuyên về an toàn thông tin, nhưng họ sẽ có một phần chuyên về học máy,
mà với phần học máy của họ thì họ lại có một phần liên quan lạc ngã.
Tức là trong cái thủ điểm của họ thì họ có một cái phần về Security thì nó làm ở trên cùng này rồi.
Ở dưới này thì có phần liên quan đến an toàn thông tin, Cyber Security, Network Security.
Tuy nhiên hội thảo này còn có phần liên quan đến AI và có phần liên quan đến các mùi liên quan đến mạng đa, mùi sinh.
Thật ra em cũng chưa nộp hội thảo bao giờ nên cũng chưa thể nộp vào mục AI hay là mục an toàn tin.
Thế thì điều kiện này em sử dụng bởi SILENCE, VDN, HOODS, QUITY để họ có mục như vậy.
Thì hiện giờ em so sánh kết quả của em
Nếu mà đúng các thí nghiệm của mình
Thì nó sẽ hơn một chút cái mùi man DNA trước đây
Và hơn cái mùi man nan nốt
Cái bộ thí nghiệm của DG
Thì đang thí nghiệm nốt 1-2 lần nữa
Để cho kết quả nó xứng nhận
Anh nghĩ về lao gì đi
Thí nghiệm của này
Bây giờ đang thầy, trong việc của bạn thầy hiệu phó đang có giấy truyền chuyển cho tôi, loạn lắm, may mắn tôi còn chạy trước.
Kiểu, như kiểu sáng nay có quyết định đã đẩy báo cáo lên sớm,
Thấy khả năng sắp xuống phân biệt mật mạng
Phân biệt mật mạng
Mà thầy lên là thầy sao?
Thầy lên là thầy ôn tư tướng
Cái đấy thầy chưa biết
Nhưng mà khả năng chưa
Bởi vì nếu mà thầy phải ở cấp quản lý cao nhất rồi
Còn thầy cũng khá trẻ
Mặc dù thầy trông khá trẻ
Nhưng mà thầy ngọt ngọt cho thầy biết
Thầy dũng khoảng
Thầy, bố tôi 8 tuổi, tôi 50 tuổi, bố tôi cũng sắp về rồi nên là bố tôi hạ tên ngoại gian, hạ quản lý nhiều, khả năng là sẽ phải hạ thành sư.
Thì biết hơi nhiều về cả công cuộc của chị Úc Vĩ Ngọc.
Mong là nhen tôi được.
Thì khả năng là sẽ đi Đại sứ quán, Đại sứ quán Tắc nước Luân Cập.
Khả năng là làm đẹp như là làm.
Nếu mà đi quốc ca với Đại Thái thì hơi nhạy cản.
Chưa biết được, khả năng cả bố mẹ tôi đi khoảng 7 năm, 6 năm rồi.
Hôm nay tôi chỉ học khoảng 60% thôi vì tôi học trên trường ấy.
Nếu mà là xe bên trường thì sẽ không học bổ sung.
Bạn đăng ký cho ai ạ?
Đăng ký cho ai ạ?
Tôi có bổ sung để học đặc sĩ, các bạn vào học đặc sĩ để học quỷ, các bạn ở bên cạnh hết.
Thế giới học đặc sĩ cũng là bổ sung trong tình huống đặc sĩ.
Không khó lắm đâu bởi vì tuyên báo là chỉ có ngôn liên quan tới tập cung ạ, với cả phòng thủ là 2 ngôn là tạm để phải làm.
Ốc cũng được 200-300k
300k em chứ
Thế là làm phòng đấy là làm phòng về những quan điểm tham đủ không?
Ừ
Anh ấy là người thích em
Em hỏi anh
Em biết anh ấy là người thích em
Nhưng anh ấy nằm lật người anh không phải là thông cá chấp
Em uống khô, xe đi
Có ai
Anh không trách đâu
Các bạn hãy đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé.
Có các điều kiện như bài hỏi, chính trị đi học, chính trị học hành, chính trị giấu lời, công nghệ, đồng hợp học hành.
Em ơi, bên anh có được đơn chuyển đối số không?
Bên anh có được gì?
Bên anh có được trọng 1 trọng 2.
À thế ạ, bên anh mình có được trọng 1 trọng 2.
Nhưng mà nhiều nơi được trọng 2, bên tổng đồng hành, cả truyền đồng số, cả truyền đồng hành.
Các bạn hãy đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Trắng tay thì 5 triệu chưa tới tay, hôm nay 5 triệu cũng rồi.
Thế hả, thật kỳ.
Thế anh nói bên kia của mình không được lực lượng an ninh mạng chuyên sách hả?
Không.
Không đọc trong luật hả?
Luật an ninh mạng là lực lượng chuyên sách, an ninh mạng là thuộc bộ quan của công phòng.
Sao anh phải đề xuất tên bộ quan kia của mình vậy?
Không được thì còn ai được?
Không gì được.
Từ lời của Tùng thôi.
Tùng được chưa?
Không.
300% thì có 1 người là tỉnh, nhà nước ngoài đấy
mà không ai đòi
không ai đòi
tỉnh chưa tới tay thì xin chào
xong rồi Tùng lại làm lực lượng ra khải đảo
mình mới nói là về kẻ mạnh
kẻ mạnh đây là ví dụ ngành giáo dục ấy
ngành giáo dục bao nhiêu năm, bao nhiêu đời nay
cứ kêu gọi mát lửa đúng không
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Chắc tỉnh giống giáo hội
Ừ
Nhưng mà hai cái cũng y đôi với nhau đấy
Rồi mấy ông nghỉ một bầy cám rồi lại nôi ra xóa lại
Một loạt phân thây
Mà người nhà đôi mà
Mua nhà mà xé hết rồi thì tự nhiên
Thế không thì cũng trả bây giờ nhỉ, đúng không ạ?
Trả được trả được
Không trả, không trả làm gì được đâu
Không trả, không trả chứ
Ông đã sai phạm, ông đã sai phạm rồi
Bây giờ ông không trả là chết
Ông ấy cũng sai, ông sẽ được nghỉ hưu. Sai là ông giải quyết cho ông ta sai.
Thế nhưng mà về tài chính, chỉ đã làm sai thì phải trả.
Quy tắc tài chính đó là có mục tiêu mà trả, nó cũng trả mà đi nợ.
Trước lượng, trước cách lưu dân.
Thế mà cái chuyện về hưu không về hưu thì ok.
Nên người ta sẽ không quay lại nữa.
Thế nhưng mà riêng tiền ấy, một cái chi sai thì, kết quả sai thì nghĩa là tiền này nó thành sai rồi.
Ông cầm tiền ấy thì có nghĩa là tiền đấy không phải của ông.
Đấy, nó giỡn đấy.
Thế là mình đoán
là nó nhằm vào cái quần tiền đấy thôi, chứ còn vì hưu hay không hưu thì chắc là cho hưu thôi.
Như thế nó cũng hơi bất cập đấy.
Bất cập, quá bất cập.
Bởi vì là cái tiêu chí của cái 1 phần 8 đấy là không xếp được cái vị trí của họ.
Nếu mà họ vẫn còn công tác thì cái vị trí của họ sẽ là khác, mức đơn của họ sẽ là khác so với hưu.
Bây giờ mình phải bắt một cái chính trị này không?
Không phù hợp, không đúng, không ý chế.
Thôi đồ sai chứ này.
Chứ là mình thì mới quyết xảy ra đâu.
Người đó nói thì nghe cái tranh luận không?
Ông Ba nói chuyện hoàn hảo chứ gì?
Ráng nói chuyện phía một xíu.
Đúng bắt đầu là ông cho nó 27.
Thế ông giải thích như thế này.
Đấy là cái hôm nay này nó đúng là khó nhận ra.
Nhưng mà vừa nhận được anh Vĩ khó khổ rồi.
Áp cái sống.
Bình thường nó không về.
Nếu không cầm nhiều tiền về quá.
Nên là nó phải hỏi lại.
Nếu chỉ về hư không.
Sẽ không ai hỏi.
Nhưng vì vừa được hư vừa cầm được khoản tiền to về.
Mấy tỷ.
Mười ba bốn tỷ như thế.
Hai ba bốn tỷ đấy.
Ba tỷ.
Nếu hơn ba tỷ.
Cấp mà cấp to.
Như là chỗ em, anh chồng, bà chị, sớm ba thủy ra đây.
Thế là gần như cao nhất.
Nhưng bộ phòng là không sao, bộ phòng là làm đúng.
Chỉ có mấy bộ, bốn bộ ở ngoài, mấy tỉnh, tạm bốn đây.
Xưa mình thấy là cái giai đoạn mà chúng ta bắt ký bác làm,
tức là bác bắt ký bác làm thì người nghĩ cũng nguy hiểm.
Thế bác nghỉ rồi thì ai đỡ nhỉ?
Sơn Văn Long Thành là một trong những ví dụ.
Hầu kiện sợ, toàn hầu kiện, đúng sai, đúng mong manh.
Thời điểm đấy phải làm thì nó mới làm được.
Chứ nếu nó không làm thì thời điểm này khó để ra giải đáp.
Người ta biết là sai nhưng vẫn sẵn phải làm.
Nhưng họ...
Đó là tiền vẫn mất.
Thằng muốn cho nghỉ thì nó sẽ nghỉ.
Còn cái thằng không muốn cho nghỉ thì nó lại...
Rau như thế đấy.
Anh Sơn là một tình hình.
Anh Sơn nói rằng là nếu bình thường anh Sơn mất phải làm thì nói chung chuyên môn vẫn tốt.
Trong đó cái thằng mà nó chả chuyên môn gì cả thì nó mất các bộ rồi.
Tức là gắn bộ là chuyên môn tốt là nó mất.
Các bộ chỉ huyên trong ngành ở ngoài các bộ khác mình mất nhiều.
Nhiều người người ta dọn người ta suy nghĩ.
Bài toán về quản lý là một cái bài toán rất lớn.
Nói chung là phải dành nhiều cái.
Hãy đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé!
Tuy nhiên bài toán về nhân sự cũng là một vấn đề
Vì khi mà ghép với hai nơi thì nó sẽ là ghép thêm ngành
Ngoài ghép đơn vị nhưng mà có ngành nữa
Thì nó dân lê câu chuyện là cái chuẩn của duy trì ngành
Thì phải bắt buộc mà phải đạt được
Nhưng mà nó rất khó trong việc đội ngũ
Thì đấy là một cái vấn đề
Có rất nhiều vấn đề khác nữa cơ
Nhưng mà em nghĩ là mỗi thời mỗi thế
Đều phải nhìn nhận và xem các lãnh đạo có tài hoặc khéo để xử lý và duy trì và sử dụng nhân lực như thế nào
Cũng giống như là thầy hay mọi người vừa nói
Tức là mình không thể nói trước được hôm nay có thể mình làm đúng, nói đúng như thế này
Nhưng mà sau một thời kỳ khác, nó lại là câu chuyện khác
Câu chuyện là mình có đủ nhìn nhận ra là mình vai trò, vị trí của mình lúc này thế nào, bức tranh toàn cục thế nào
Nó lại là một câu chuyện mà phải đòi hỏi một cái tư duy của những người ấy là nó đủ một tầm thôi thôi
Đáng đình giá cho tới những ai nghỉ hưu, mình cũng đang nghĩ nghỉ hưu về là phải Youtuber thôi
Ôi thầy
Nhưng mà làm ảnh thì Youtuber vì giặt mặt mình quá
Thầy
Ăn cũng đau mà, quay ăn cũng đau mà
Tới vừa, quay nửa
Nói chuyện xuyên
Vậy hả
Vẫn mấy cái thằng dầu mặt
Cái đấy thực ra bản chất em nghĩ là nó thu lợi của YouTube quá nhiều mà nó lại lọt vào ngân sách nhà nước nhiều quá.
Đâm ra là bắt đầu nó mới bằng vì lợi cá nhân nhiều mà nhà nước không được hưởng lợi thì đấy thôi.
Những người đầu trò đánh điển hình thôi.
Chứ còn sẽ rất nhiều người...
Tôi thấy là nước nước mình hay là có một giai đoạn là để trưng quán, trưng quán là không hút đoạn đâu.
Thì có một giai đoạn là nó cũng làm ăn tốt, hoặc là không tốt.
sau đến lúc nhà nước bắt bổ loạn thì bắt đầu hữu dụng
Vì YouTuber cũng thế, lần này khác làm nhiều ổn định hơn
Vâng
Phải thế thôi Thầy, năm 2020, 2019 toàn mấy cái ảnh hưởng xấu dưới trẻ
Mỗi cái xấu thôi, nhưng mà đi làm ăn đi, làm ăn là xuống thuế thôi
Thứ này là dễ ợt, thế là không xuống được
Như là Youtube hoặc là các cái doanh nghiệp Mỹ lại không có những chi nhánh ở Việt Nam
nên không phải đóng thuế quá nhiều mới phải làm.
Mình nhớ thằng tên đó là Hải Sapa, thịt châu Ấn Độ.
Nếu so với thằng kia thì nó bình thường thôi nhỉ?
Nó không quá lây dưỡng, chắc nó còn hư lậu không?
Hải Sapa, Hải Sapa.
Nó chắc là mùi cội gì cả.
Nhưng mà thuế của Hải Sapa là nhiều nhất.
Em thấy một bài viết nói một tổng thể của Hải Sapa
Đầu tiên là chỉ lái xe du lịch, sau đó là qua các liên lạc về mặt truyền thông thì bắt đầu mới làm ITUBI
ITUBI sau bắt đầu mới quen đội Huấn Hoa Hồng rồi là Phú Lê lập đội anh em Kết Nghĩa Vườn Đào
thì bắt đầu là cái mảng làm cái mảng đấy
và cộng với cái đội của cái mảng của Hoàng Phú Lê
cái thứ là làm cái YouTube
nhưng mà bản chất của YouTube đấy lại kết hợp nhau là làm các cái bán kinh doanh ở trong nữa
và trong đấy thì một trong những cái việc ấy là đó chính là quảng bá các cái sản phẩm trong đó là có cái thịt trâu
ngoài ra thì có rất nhiều những cái quảng bá đương nhiên là làm YouTube nói các quảng bá thì đúng sự thật
Mình nói là thịt châu chỉ là lý do thôi
Chỉ là một cái lý do
Mình biết lịch sử là nó chơi thằng Huấn với thằng Phú Lê
Thằng nữa đấy
Vì 3 thằng khác nhau
Nhưng mà 2 thằng kia theo đường sâu đen thì thằng Hải Thái Quang tách ra
Thằng Hải Thái Quang thì về mặt sâu đen là nó đớn nhất trong 3 thằng đấy
Nhưng mà chắc nó còn một số thứ còn nhầm
Nhưng mà thịt châu Bắc Bếp là một trong những tùy nhấn, tùy lớn
Tùy lớn, bây giờ nếu mà tính qua 30 tỷ là nó là tùy to
Châu Ấn Độ, châu Ước Vận Ấn Độ, châu của Việt Nam làm sao nó làm được
Với lại cả 3 cái đội đấy đều là quyên có tiền tài trợ rất nhiều, lấy tiền tài trợ đấy nhưng mà tiền tài trợ rất nhiều
Nhưng mà thực ra là tất cả các tiền tài trợ của các đơn vị ấy mà lấy
Mình thì không phải xin tội, doanh nghiệp về văn hóa thì xin tội, nếu mà đúng không phải xin tội
Đúng rồi, không sai cái này thì không sai cái này
Hôm nay có một bài báo của một cầu giám đốc của công ty về tòa thuế của Đà Nẵng
Đưa lên rằng là thân lập dân nghiệp thì được mận 2 triệu, nhưng mà giải thể dân nghiệp thì mận gần 2 tất triệu.
Nghĩa là giải thể quá khó.
Thầy, anh xin các đồng chí ký viết vào xe.
Vâng, em sẽ trả lời cho tuyến nhé.
Dạ vâng, em sẽ trả lời cho tuyến nhé.
Thân lập dân nghiệp thì gì anh ạ?
Thân lập giải thể khó lắm.
Dạ, thưa thầy.
Cảm ơn thầy.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Thế nên là anh chân trí lại nó cũng đáng
Làm ơn để có một kỳ xảo thì chỉ có việc là dựa cái kỳ xảo đấy thì đúng
Nếu như mà điều tra cho đúng thì nó đúng
Mà không cho đúng thì nó là sai
Ví dụ em đơn giản một cái, đơn giản như này
vô đôi là có các thứ là sửa ứng, sửa bột, sửa bột nhưng mà thực ra cả cái bột mình xay trở thành là sửa ví dụ sửa bột đầu nành này
rồi cả cái bột đầu xanh tất cả mình xay, nhưng mà đi kiểm tra lúc đó là nó đủ, thân thân là chuẩn
nhưng mà khi đưa ra bán ở ngoài cả hàng thì nhiệt độ đủ thực tiểu nó tác động vào
Khi nó giảm xuống một chút, bình thường là 5%, bây giờ chỉ có 488 thôi.
Thì sản phẩm đấy sẽ được quý vào là bộ bản hàng giảm.
Nó chỉ thấp một chút, nó sẽ trở thành bộ bản hàng giảm rồi.
Bởi vì theo cái thông số mà bạn đăng ký là nó 5%, bây giờ tự nhiên là 488 thôi.
Thay việc là tất cả mọi cái chất nó đều có sự biến đổi hết.
Như chúng ta cũng giữ trong môi trường, nó đúng, nó không đúng, do phần chuyển ra cái gì thì nó sẽ sai số
Nó sai số đưa ra là đương nhiên là quý vào thằng giả luôn, thằng giả kém chất lượng, nó nguy hiểm thế
Ngay cả cái bảng đầu sánh của Hải Dương chẳng hạn, ai dám thăng bín ra là cái tiêu chuẩn đấy nó chuẩn lắm
Khi mà đưa ra thị trường xáy rồi ép rồi thế nào đưa ra thị trường cái thân phần nó bỏ
Nó khó, nó khó chỗ đấy
Nên khi mà bọc tách ra
Là dễ lắm
Dễ lắm
Rất mong man
Kiểu như tu tung mà đi sói
Ai sói thì làm sao nó thoát được
Bản quyền
Em bảo thay là bản quyền
Nó đơn giản thế này
Thực ra ở Việt Nam mình mua được bản quyền
Mua rất dễ, nhưng mà
Đầy cả cái bản quyền đầy lấy
nó sẽ trở nên rất đắt
cái máy tính bình thường thì chỉ có 12 hay 3 triệu
bây giờ thêm nữa, trở khoảng 3 triệu nữa
một cái bản quyền
bản quyền là Win, sau đó là Office nữa
Office thì nếu như Office zoom ngoài mạng
thì cũng đâu đó trở khoảng gần 4 triệu
đấy, gần 4 triệu, chưa kể
Office của Photoshop, chưa kể đến
các cái phần bên khác thì còn vào
cái máy đấy nó không phải là 13 triệu nữa
rất là lắm, thì đương nhiên là
sinh viên của mình làm sao
là cái đó, truyền truyền không tưởng
Đơn giản như thế đó. Ví dụ như nhà em, nhà em có 4 máy tính, bởi vì tất cả đều bằng bản quyền thì cái tối lương nó khủng khiếp.
Thế nên nó bây giờ đúng thì kiểm tra thì thiệt sự sai, chứ không kiểm tra nữa.
Việt Nam của mình bây giờ, em nói thầy, các trường đại học, ví dụ trường mật khoa chẳng hạn, có bao nhiêu sinh viên dùng bản quyền của photoshop, đúng không ạ?
hoặc là phần mềm AutoCAD. Những phần mềm đấy thì có AutoLib.
Đấy.
Nó phải bắt mua nguyên cả tổng Adobe.
Rồi chia kể đến các phần mềm AutoCAD, quả rất là đắt.
AutoLib, vẻ mặt điện, những phần mềm trên trường tiện ăn học đắt.
Đấy chỉ có thể tải nguồn không trình thống.
Đấy, tải nguồn không trình thống nghĩa là lỗ.
không có bằng quyền gì nữa
hoặc là ông dùng cả cái trang để crack cái gì
ông đi lọc cái gì nữa
có những vấn đề cực kỳ nát dài
đúng hay sai
công nghiệp hàng tỷ, hàng tỷ cho em đi
20 năm cho em đi, hàng tỷ cái sai
chỉ đâu chẳng sai
vấn đề là có bắt hay không
ông muốn gì mới trả lời không?
em chưa muốn gì gì
không hướng hơn, cho nên có thể là kết hợp cả cái hướng file, giảm hướng, tempo, kế năng chạy, xong rồi.
Mình rất hy vọng bài tổng gửi này được chấp nhận.
Bài mình thấy cũng về mặt chất lượng.
Hai tuần nữa.
Nhanh nhất.
Hy vọng thế, cũng được một tuần thôi.
Phấn mới gửi cái gì đấy Phấn?
Phấn gửi bài bảo, em cũng viết thành.
Được xong rồi có gì không? Có gì đặc biệt?
Chi tiết mình sẽ đọc.
Có thể là con bơ đôi của em có cao hơn cái slide của bà Nguyễn Văn.
Chị cũng chắc là Nguyễn Văn đi nhà.
Chị cũng phải đi cùng với anh.
Thầy đi kìa.
Dạ chí mà cũng rất là đồng ý với anh.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Thì nó hợp hợp với mình thôi
Còn có thể em cũng tham khảo cái template của nó
Đầu thời trong mấy cái tuần vừa qua thì em cũng thử khá là nhiều
Đó viết bản báo này
Trong bản báo này thì dự kiến là tên của bản template
Chọn form 1 with F L H A
Cái này là F A có nghĩa là
Front Level Feature Residual
And D M I H A có nghĩa là
Typical Mass Attention
Đi cái tên này là tổng viên tập có cái rối não rồi
Đúng rồi
Viên thắng lại
Bỏ viên thắng lại
Bỏ cái tên này đi
Không biết tên này chắc chắn là tổng viên tập khác nhau rồi
Em đưa cái tên này để nhấn mặn 2 cái phương pháp trong mô hình nhấn mặn hơn
Cái bài báo thì em cũng đã báo rồi
Cơ bản của mô hình tương tự như hôm trước em đã báo cáo thầy
Đầu tiên sẽ qua bước sử dụng diện
Sau đó sẽ qua backbone sử dụng Connect ID
Sau khi qua backbone Connect ID
Nó sẽ trình xuất ra các đặc trưng trong mỗi mũi frame trong video
Thật này rõ ràng rồi
Sau đó nó sẽ chiếu các frame này
Điều này gồm chiếu các cụm này để đưa qua một cái gọi là Frame Level Feature Residual
Đối với cái Frame Level Feature Residual này, mục đích chính của nó là để mà nó sẽ bắt các cái thông tin khác nhau giữa các cái frame
Nếu các bạn so sánh giữa các cái frame với nhau thì ở trong đấy nó sẽ có các cái thông tin vô địch, thông tin tính
Đối với các cái thông tin tĩnh đấy thì cái frame thứ nhất và cái frame thứ hai cũng hợp tương đổi nhau.
Ở đây thì mình sẽ chọn ra được các cái đặc trưng mà nó khác nhau,
không sử dụng các đặc trưng giống nhau lắm.
Thế thì cái tính năng này cũng gần tương tự như là đối với một cái tính năng gọi là self-subtract
ở trong cái bài báo AST của một cái team mà nó đang ở
trên cái IEA của năm 2023
cái bản đó thì nó cũng khá là được áp dụng, được khám chiếu khá nhiều
và cái bản đó thì tùy cho cái lượng chính xác của crop attention
của crop data set rơi vào 84%
cho đến bây giờ thì đối với nội dung mô hình thích hợp
đối với cái cảnh thời gian, thời gian tạo chiếu, cái bài báo rất là nhiều.
Sau khi thực hiện quá trình để mà trích xuất các đặc trưng khác nhau
giữa các frame ở trong một cái video sẽ được mang
cái mô hình Transformer Handcorder, tại cái mô hình Transformer Handcorder
không phải giống như cái Transformer Handcorder thông thường.
Và đây sẽ sử dụng cái cơ chế như là DLModal Max Interframe Shell Attention
có nghĩa là sẽ che chính nó đi
để từ các cái frame khi mà so sánh với nhau
thì nó sẽ không so sánh với chính nó
khi mà nó so sánh với chính nó thì
cái giá trị mà so sánh với chính nó
thì nó sẽ cao nhất so với tất cả
cái việc mà so sánh với các cái frame khác
Đấy là hai cái tư chế mà đề xuất ở trong cái mô hình này
Trong bài báo anh cũng có giải thích cơ chế đó, có thử nghiệm trong bài báo này đối với tầng học.
Vâng, bây giờ mình sẽ giải thích.
Phụ thể đối với tổng số, frame là 106 triệu tham số.
Có nghĩa là đối với cơ chế của 106 triệu tham số, nó cũng sẽ lớn hơn khá nhiều so với môi trường trước đây.
Ví dụ như là Zencomics thì nó là 600 triệu, đối với Instability thì nó gần 200 triệu, với môn kẻ của em nó là 116 triệu.
Có lẽ là cụ thể về đối với các giải thích thì xem thêm như thế này.
Khi mình xem phần introduction, phần ca lợi, ca lợi mình làm cái gì mà nó thấy hay.
Đối với phần introduction này thì chủ nghĩa là nói đến việc là hiện nay đối với các mô hình hiện nay trong việc phát hiện feedback,
Về cơ bản, đối với các kết quả và đánh giá trên nội tập là nó gần gần đã bão mạ rồi
Có nghĩa là độ chính xác hoặc các chỉ số AUC gần như tuyệt đối rồi
Nên sự so sánh sẽ không thiên về nội tập nữa
mà nó chủ yếu là so sánh đối với là điên tập
có nghĩa là huấn luyện ở trên cái tập trí liệu này và kể thử ở trên cái tập trí liệu khác
Thì cụ thể trong cái bài này của em cũng là huấn luyện ở trên những cái tập trí liệu
Phase Forensics hoặc là DC
và test ở trên cái tập trí liệu là Select NS
có nghĩa là test ở trên cái tập trí liệu lên tập
Thì đối với các bài báo đến nay thì thông thường khi mà huấn luyện ở trên tập trí liệu
Ví dụ như Face Forex chẳng hạn, test ở trên tập như là của SelectDF thường là nó sẽ rơi xuống cái độ chính xác
Cái AUC của nó thì nó sẽ rơi xuống khoảng, nếu mà test ở trên cái độ tập thì nó khoảng 99%
Nhưng mà khi mà nó test ở trên cái độ tập thì nó sẽ rơi xuống khoảng 60-75% thôi
Kể cả là đối với mô hình gian Covid thì nó cũng test liên tập thì nó chỉ rơi được khoảng tầm trên 50%
Khi mà test, test thì cũng chắc cái bộ dữ liệu liên tập
Thì cũng chính vì như thế nên là đối với các loại bảo vệ
Bây giờ mình nghĩ rằng là phát hiện effect, kế sức môi hồ sâu cũng không bị về mặt nghiệp trụ sinh năm nay
Nói chung là cái mô hình mới ở đây có nghĩa là đề xuất một cái mô hình để mà có thể phát hiện feedback nhưng mà nó phải có hạt hóa tốt hơn so với các cái mô hình hiện tại.
Tổng phát hóa thể hiện là vấn đề trên một cái mổ dữ liệu và kiểm tra trên một cái mổ dữ liệu mà chưa nhìn thấy.
Thì nó phải là inter-dataset đúng không?
Thì cái inter-dataset nó nằm ở đâu trong cái phần extract và installation?
Inter-dataset nằm ở đây
Ờ
Đây, thì cái ngay đầu tiên của em là Ngu nói cái phần inter-dataset ở đây
Có thể hệ trên tiêu đề nữa không?
Trong phần tiêu đề là nói rồi
Theo tiêu đề là từ nào?
Tiêu đề đúng không? Title đúng không?
À, Title thì cũng không
Bây giờ mình về cao hình này, 75 effect đề xuất một hộp show, rất nhiều người nói
Kẻ em có đề xuất lên khoảng 95% của em nên sau khi mở trang của họ, 8-9% thì nó cũng không có gì mới cả
Đúng chưa? Nó chỉ là một loài mặt kỹ thuật thôi
Thế bây giờ, cái vấn đề mà em giải quyết mà thiệt là sự đột phá đây nó là cái gì?
Đấy, thì phải chăng đó là Inter Domain, Cross Domain
Thì Cross Domain này nó được thể hiện tầm quan trọng ở chỗ nào trong tất cả cái kinh tế này
Cái đấy thì ở trong tool này thì em chưa thể hiện cái việc đó
Nhưng mà trong HeadTrack thì đã thể hiện rồi
Rồi, HeadTrack, tức là ở trong intro hoặc trong tất cả nó có mục riêng cho Cross Domain kinh tế này sẽ được
Không, nó không có mục riêng
Mà thể hiện trong các nội dung
Vẫn này không?
Vẫn này không
Sau mấy bài tạp chí vừa rồi
Họ không đồng ý với bài này
Tại vì nghĩ lại nó có thể rõ hơn
Đa số họ nghĩ là
Mình đề xuất một phương pháp
Giữa trường sâu
Cảm thấy gì đó để
Nhưng họ cảm thấy chưa có gì đáng giá
Với đặc biệt trên các tạp chí lớn
Trên tạp chí lớn họ muốn là
Bài này cũng đề xuất một vấn đề gì đấy mà thực sự nó là mới
Cho em thầy hỏi thử một câu
Nếu em nói là trên cross domain nó là vấn đề quan trọng
và ít thằng nó tới
Thì mình có thể tiêu đề cho nó tới một mục riêng
Vừa rồi mình thấy ông chỉ có mỗi lần
Thấy thằng này làm hay, thằng này làm hay
Ông ghép hai thằng hay với nhau
Đấy, để trở thành một cái thang để trả lời người đấy thì nó gọi chứ gì, đồng ý là được rồi.
Ok, tốt, tốt nhưng chưa phải là, nó gọi là gì, good but not enough.
Đấy, interesting nhưng mà, I'm sorry.
Cái interesting but I'm sorry is not enough.
Chưa đủ. Đấy.
Thế thì, thế thì thầy nhận là gì?
Cái, cái điểm nhấn của mình là chưa đúng trong tầm tầm quan tâm.
Thầy rất ghi nhận cái, đó có phải thầy thấy rất hay.
Nhưng mà bản thân tạp chí người ta chưa đúng với quan tâm của họ
Thế bây giờ ta phải bàn kia nhau xem là cái vấn đề chính mà em quên coi ấy
Điểm vất vả mà người ta đang muốn giải quyết nó là
Mình thực toán thì chắc là khó rồi đúng không?
Thực toán là mình lắp ghép cải tiến rồi
Thế nhưng mà mình phải đánh nó sang miền nước nữa
Nó là cái gì?
Thế em thấy là đúng hạt vị cross-battaset ok?
Vâng, chính là cái đấy
Trong 6 hạt hóa này em đều hướng đến cái đấy
Thế em hiện tư chưa đề cho tới một trong...
Trong cái phần introduction này của em là đều xoay quanh về vấn đề cross-domain
Phần extract cũng xoay
vấn đề raw format, nhưng mà Châu cần tiêu đề, chứ không thể.
Trong tất cả những phần ở dưới cũng đều đề cập đến kiến nghiệm đánh giá trên một bộ dữ liệu khác,
một bộ dữ liệu chưa nhìn thấy, để tăng kết quả của một bộ dữ liệu chưa nhìn thấy.
Trong tất cả các nội dung ở dưới đều đánh giá như thế này.
Các luận giải, các chứng minh cũng nói về việc đó. Trong đấy, em cũng thử khoảng tầm 55 lần rồi mới lại.
Thế bây giờ nó sẽ đặt ngay trên đầu, lên tiêu đề thì ta đặt ra câu hỏi là
Nếu đặt ra tiêu đề là temporal complex cho defective variation in cross domain gì đấy, ra thống của cross domain này có được không?
Lúc đầu em cũng nghĩ như thế rồi, nhưng em thấy là nó chưa nhấn mắt 2 cái FL, FR với MI, F2
Thế FL này là 1 cái đặc trái quan tâm, chỉ tổ theo cấu ấy, nó rảnh luôn
Đấy, ưu đề là nó thấy sức bình dị mà nó rõ ràng thể hiện được cái điểm nhấn mình
Tất cả những thêm bộ bằng Break Timeformer, Network, Defective Duration nó là tầm thường rồi đó
Thế bây giờ cái phần thường đề đó là cross domain thì em được không?
Thế còn cái FL, DMI em à, nếu mà thường thường nó hay thì em giữ tả nó bằng 1, 2 câu mà nó không phải cứ tắt gạch, em thấy hiểu không?
Đấy, đối với cross domain ấy
Vâng, thực ra là trong toàn bộ cái bài này thì cái cross domain mới là cái chính mà em nhắm đến
Chính thế, cho nên là nếu đúng như thế thì ngay từ tiêu đề cho tới thì có trong một cách nhất
Đọc phát là thấy product name nó tràn đọc được
Và chưa thật nào làm được điều đấy thì mình làm thành bản
Thì thật ra nếu em làm như thế thì mình nghĩ là sẽ ăn điện
Kết quả sau của Thuấn mình nghĩ là có rất thậm chí
Cá nhân mình nghĩ chẳng làm thêm được cả
Cái vấn đề là làm thế nào để đặt nó vào đúng cái điểm rơi thôi
Thế là cái điểm giữ cho nó quan tâm
Đấy
Cái cách mà mình làm người ta cứ thấy đều đều đều
Nó cũng giống như người khác làm thôi
Đấy
Thế này này hai này hai
Xộn vào nhau đúng không
Đấy kiểu thế
Thực tế cũng phải
Chứ cái không phải đấy mình làm là giỏi
Thế thôi
Thế thôi những kinh nghiệm của em mình nghĩ là quá đầy đủ
Chứ không phải là đầy đủ vừa
Dạ em nghĩ là kinh nghiệm
Tổng kinh nghiệm
Mình có
Mình đã
Mình đã đi khai mỏ, mình đã có người bảo địa về, mình đã đóng hành vàng khối rồi
Nhưng vấn đề là cho thị trường biết cái vàng khối của mình là sản chất, ngon, hơn cái sản khác
Đấy là nhiệm vụ của tôi
Thì qua những trả lời mình muốn hỏi, tự hóa chính là cái gì thì nếu em nói là crossroom lên tự hóa chính thì em phải thu nó
Thấy không? Hiền có ý gì xin bài không Hiền?
Dạ thôi Hiền
Mình nói trước lần bài cái khách ăn ngon rồi, làm thế nào để gắn vào luận án này thôi?
Em thì cũng có bụi, em báo cáo thế giới em cũng dựa trên cơ bài đấy, cầm gửi cho cơ bài, xin các bạn tính
Câu hỏi này ra nhé, nếu mà mình làm luận án để học sâu cho phát hiện tính tiện thì điểm nhấn nó là cái gì?
Từ mặt học thuật, nó là cái gì mà người ta chưa giải quyết được?
Có thể là em nghĩ ra là cái bài mà ở các em
Nếu như mà thay mà em được
Thì em nghĩ ra là em đang giải quyết vấn đề của
Thì mai ra được con nữ như tình anh thì chắc chắn sẽ
Và em sẽ tập trung theo cái hướng là thức việc
Cơ sở dự liệu bây giờ thì cơ sở dự liệu thì được cả 1.500 bản tin
Cộng với hơn 1.500 bản tin từ xin và ảnh
Thế để cuốn bài thì em phải thay bỏ ý lộ sai
Mình vừa mới ký qua cái mẫu, mình nhận được các slide phải đúng không ạ?
Thì bài thì mình có rốt, mình cũng làm thế nào rồi.
Các mẫu là cái nội dung đó của các slide cho nó hoàn thiện.
Mình chỉ nói cho các em là tất cả các chủ đề của các chương trình ở đây,
thường xuyên các em phải khảo sát xem là người ta đã làm được gì.
Người ta đang làm thì người ta sẽ làm gì?
Trong tất cả những công trình, nếu các em vào năm 2026,
thì các em phải khảo sát đến tận tháng 9 năm 2026 để xem người ta làm được gì.
Thì mình biết là xu hướng thế nào
Và khi xu hướng thế nó ra thì người ta làm nhiều ở lĩnh vực này
Thì đương nhiên nếu mình làm ở đây là làm ở đá
Đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà người ta làm ở phía Bắc thì mình làm ở phía Nam
Phía Nam là làm cái gì? Đúng không?
Đấy tức là mình phải đặt hết để xem người ta làm cái gì
Tiếng Việt đúng là đúng những người ít người khai thác
Thế nhưng mà đặc trưng nó là cái gì thì em cũng phải nói thành lời
Thì mình cũng phải biết được
Vì cái tiếng Việt như thế này
Phải làm được cái đáp là xe của người thầy
Một bản data sẽ phổ biến cho mình cái chất khóa để chia sẻ ra được
Và em để ý cái đó thêm một cái gọi là cái vỉnh mặt của mình luôn
Rồi, nhận được. Ok. Vinh, sử dụng
Bây giờ thầy hỏi Vinh là cái kết quả đó thì thầy đặt ra yêu cầu là
Trong tháng 9 em ra được cái bài mà thả ra
Đang viết một bản draft, một bản kinh nghiệm
Một bản khác mà nói với mình ý, viết ngay từ đầu một tiếng Anh
Ý là em cũng có một bản về thiết kế này rồi, nhưng mà mấy hôm nay đợt kỷ lễ kết quả em báo cáo thầy là 0,59.
Giờ này em lại tỏ cáo là 0,86, tức là cái đợt đấy giảm sát lại thì nó không kết nối.
Xong rồi về sau giảm sát lại thì may mắn là đọc được sớm.
Em rất tự tin là có thể xung quanh được cái tạp chí khi lần đấy đi.
Em nghĩ chủ đề cũng rất là sáng.
Tự nhiên em chảy gì cũng không biết.
Vừa rồi mình mua rất nhiều cái bản án cũng thấy là...
Các bạn em cũng nói trời biển thì nhưng mà trong các cái phần thương tích so sánh em mà không có công trình set-up của em thì hãy tìm.
Năm 2026 mà em không so sánh với những cái công trình so sánh trở về trước, làm năm mùa năm trước thì không hãy tìm.
Có lẽ em so sánh với các dạng của cái bộ thư viện đấy thôi. Các dạng bộ thư viện đấy thì họ cũng khá là chăm chỉ.
Hai công hay tư học suốt một năm, hai năm học suốt vài năm nữa xong rồi đang ở cài để sử dụng.
Như vậy sắp tới nha, cái OECD thì Việt Nam đang kiếm một bài đúng không?
Cái này thì là diện rồi, mình là làm rồi đúng không?
Cái gì chai, cái này thì quên
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Đúng hay là thầy còn đang bán bất là suy nghe hết rồi
Nhưng mà thầy chưa thể hiện bày cái phần rì buột là không
Muốn đi show được thuật toán, đóng góp thuật toán
Thì cái đấy mới là cái trọng răng
Em phải trình bày sắp tới, em phải rõ ràng ra
Rì buột được tính như thế nào
Tính như thế nào và ảnh hưởng của rì buột này nó như thế nào
Và mình cải thiện cái gì mà liên quan đến rì buột
Và đối với như là nếu em tiếp tục làm du sinh thì
Thì em thấy bài toán rất có ý nghĩa, bài toán sinh được cái chuỗi, cái sự tích.
XQL đấy mà ứng dụng được thì quá xứng đáng vào luật án luôn.
Cũng mong có cái tương lai lạc quan thế.
Tương lai như nơi khác còn nằm sự tích nào.
Đã tích thì giá tích hẳn luôn.
Mà lần này thì em sẽ chỉ tập trung vào 2 phương án là smoth với cả si quần gan chứ không cần phải quan tâm cái kiểu.
Sư luận gan, em tập trung sư luận gan cho thầy
Và em làm hết mức để thủ đoàn đấy chạy tối đa với tỉ thường gốc giấy của nó
Và sau đó là thầy phải cải thiện nó
Thầy có nhiều ý tưởng cải thiện nó nhưng mà thầy muốn em phải hiểu về nó
Lúc thạc sĩ thì ok, thạc sĩ thế này em hoàn thành xuất sắc
Như vậy là 15 tháng 51 là hạng của FGK
Như vậy em sẽ có từ tháng 9 tháng 10
5 tuần, 10 tuần
Thế thôi, tới vào cuối tuần
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Cái này sư phụ thấy là sáng rồi, nhưng mà với quả ngoại nữ thì đúng là ngoài tầm
Ngoài tầm của không lưu trưởng được hết
Chỉ còn để mà xong cái kệ đấy thì em là vào làm
Nhưng mà thôi thì viết chứ gì thế, phải chấp nhận
Em không dúng tiếng Anh lên, em còn dúng cũng chỉ là
Dù làm đi trường vào rồi nhưng mà quả nữ của hai em cần tăng cường
Sáng này ai cũng mới xong
Tiếng Anh học thuật thì em cũng ok nhưng mà để mà nói chuyên ngành thì cũng hiếm
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Tập ra 1, 2 lần học thảo cũng là quen và chỉ để có kinh ngạc du lịch.
Nếu mình đã biết là học thảo quen thì bài thảo khác cũng rất là dễ lấy.
Nếu mình đã được một bài thảo chính quen thì sao các bài thảo chính khác cũng rất dễ.
Cũng giải thích được điều đó nhưng nó là sự ngạc.
Đấy là sự ngạc.
Như Lam biết học thảo trong nước ok rồi đúng không?
Nhưng nếu em cố được bài thảo chính thì sau đó các bài thảo chính em sẽ...
Lúc đầu rất là khó khăn nhé, tạp chí gọi là quay đi quay lại mãi nhưng mà nếu chỉ cần mua lần vào thì lần sau sẽ rất là xếp
Hiển thị lần này vào cái lần sau nghe cũng tùy tới
Vừa rồi Tùng viết cái bài tạp chí của mình thấy nó khác hẳn với tạp chí đúng không?
Đúng
Các hẳn luôn
Nhưng mà mình vẫn đoán các em là đối với tạp chí, cái người cộng với Tập thì khi ta đăng những bài các em thì người tạp chí bắt được đúng từ một từ khoá
Cái mới đó là cái gì? Cái mới đó là nếu chúng ta bắt được phản ánh của mình thì người ta sẽ rất ok với mình, người ta sẽ cho đi phản biệt.
Còn nếu chúng ta không bắt được người ta nghĩ là chỉ là ông Sáu đó làm cái kia kia là xong.
Thì người ta sẽ cho mình một bạch ngay ở góc an ra.
Thế thôi. Cái cảnh này em biết là thời buổi AI bài xong biết liên tục nhiều lắm.
Thoa rồi.
Thoa rồi còn mình xác tổng Covid rồi.
Không biết là Covid không, tự dưng một ngày là tự dưng một ngày.
Mình cũng đã từng Covid được cách đây nhưng mà hôm nay tự dưng Covid không.
Em bị ướt mười ngày rồi.
Mình không xuyên nghiệp nhưng mà chịu chứng mình thấy đối với Covid ngày xưa mình bị quả không?
Em ho là do. Em có bị trước nhỉ lấy, khi hồng nó...
Vì em hồng thì nó mưa hồng...
Tôi nghĩ chắc em bắn bóng thôi cho máy thôi.
Cho thầy quán ra cho thầy xem.
Đi máy.
Nên thầy không đi xe nữa.
Tưởng thấy chung này ra đi sớm và thầy ngồi vào người trước
Thầy bảo thầy đang ở tận đâu ấy
Cho mình một tiếng ngồi vì thế
Chúng ta nhận được một quán
Và sau đó cái gì ấy
Hôm vừa thầy Trung còn nói
Đi đâu thì đi tìm bà vi hay sao
Đi trong này thôi chứ
Không phải ngồi ở nhà một đấy
Đi đi
Chứ anh ngồi bên hồn
Anh ngồi bên hồn kia
Anh ngồi bên hồn
Hãy subscribe cho kênh La La School Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
báo cáo cũng
Cũng thầy hơi gấp
Nhưng ông đấy là
Một thầy về ông đấy là
Thầy nhục phó là phải
Phải đợi gần
Nghĩa là hẹn từ sáng
Cuối cùng là cứ đẩy lùi 1 tiếng dần
Đến 4h mới báo cáo được
Thế là ông đấy là em đến trường từ 8h
Xong cứ ngồi dưới thư viện
Đến 4h tư
Xong rồi
Các cô lùi xuống 3h30
Là chốt
Xong rồi ngồi đến 4 giờ thì thầy mới xong
Đấy là may mà em còn được báo cáo sớm
Còn lớp em là tự nhiên là đang nói là đến tháng 12 là báo cáo
Đẩy luôn hành đến tháng 10 báo cáo
Bạn, bao nhiêu người đang chết
Tuần sau là cũng đợi báo cáo
À vâng, tuần sau là đã phải ngồi
Kiểu vừa thông báo còn đúng 5 ngày nộp
Nên là bao nhiêu người đang đi công tác xa phải ngủi hết
Đang hơi loạn
Làm cái trường này có quyết định đi học chưa?
hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Các bạn có thể nhìn thấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể lấy tổng tiểu của ông cũng có thể l
Vậy là sao anh sử dụng được cái mô hình tính tác để giải quyết các cái đặc biệt của những loại vật xong?
Em ạ, em bảo thầy...
Khá giống với ba lô hình này mà.
Em bảo...
Để bảo sát anh bảo lại, chắc anh dùng ba lô lừa quá, chắc là mấy anh em nhìn nó che thế nào đấy.
Em bảo bảo với thầy cái ba lô đấy là em gửi Nam chọn, thấy hả?
Đấy, em gửi Nam chọn và ngươi đi trực tiếp ra cái hang của bạn Nam.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Thầy là màu xanh navi, em cũng thuộc màng đấy
Thầy thấy đồ của em toàn là màu ấy
Tất cả điện thoại cố gắng là được màu đấy
Cho nên khi chọn cái tuổi đẹp thầy nó cũng khá là sáng
Nó sáng và nó cũng khá là tự động như màu hình này đúng không anh?
Chứ chứa hỏng thì làm sao bỏ đây?
Chứa hỏng
Em bảo cầu thầy này
Tôi đã từng có một quan điểm rằng là
Cứ như cái nào khi đến học thì ấy
Nhưng mà bây giờ dùng đồ thầy
Kể cả áo quân em thấy
Cứ có cái người đó mình sử dụng cả
Cứ dùng là thầy
Không thể chờ được
Có những thứ không thể chờ được
Nói cho các bạn là cái ví thầy nhé
Mình mới thay nhưng mà
Mình dùng cái ví trước nó là
15 năm
Quân của em đi từ khi
Thêm điểm khi ở OM, 10 thi quân thì mau đấy
Thế là OM nó khắc bó, nó huy động từ Hải Phong, từ Hải Dương lên
Chân ra riêng, tụi bé mới toan đúng màu ấy
Hôm trước là màu này ạ, lúc đầu là 2 em bạn này
Màu này ạ
Đấy, màu này là màu Navi tên thôi
Đấy, cái màu này tại mình tên đẹp rồi đấy
Và sao mình cứ bảo là tại ông dùng nhiều cái đấy quá, mọi người chú ý
Hãy subscribe cho kênh La La School Để không bỏ lỡ
2 em tìm tính là thay cái túi để cái pick
nhưng mà màu trắng hết rồi
nhưng mà em lại sợ giấy nó bằng màu trắng
cả từ 2 năm ra rồi
màu trắng như kiểu mình hộp hết rồi
ngày xưa mình nói hiểu là ngày xưa trời mình còn chưa về học gần rồi này
là mình cũng toàn dùng cặp thôi
giống như vẫn là
sau một hồi mình thấy nó không tiện lắm
cái ba lô mình thấy đúng nhiều thứ hơn là cặp
Thế thì 2 anh em bảo phải mua một cái gì đấy mà thầy có thể ra dùng trước
Ví dụ như cái bá lô mà anh em đang thay ấy là thầy có thể bỏ kích vào trong đấy cũng được
Vừa đựng được, kể cả laptop cũng được mà đi đâu cũng có thể đi
Thì nó mới phù hợp
Nhưng mà anh em có nghĩ là nếu như có thể nổi thay như 1 trẻ
Nó cũng phải trân thủ ra
Nên không thể để được
Các bạn hãy đăng ký kênh để ủng hộ kênh của mình nhé.
Các bạn có thể thay đổi quy chế của thầy Phó với quy chế của bộ?
Chắc là có quy chế của thầy Phó.
Đúng ạ, có quy chế của thầy Phó.
Thầy Phó có khả năng sẽ rời đi, thay đổi quy chế của thầy Phó.
Không, quy chế của bộ thì khó chứ gì.
Em nghĩ là yêu cầu về tuyển sinh, nghiên cứu sinh sẽ thay đổi khá nhiều.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh La La School Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn